So Donald Trump is again defending golfing
this weekend, even as multiple states are
hitting new single day highs in terms of new
Corona virus cases.
And he's defending golfing with a really strange
rant about how it's his exercise.
And anyway, Obama played more golf, which
isn't true.
And he's getting work done on the golf course
and he's rushing through the holes anyway
so that nobody should really be mad.
It's bizarre.
But before we get to it, understand the context.
The context is Trump has spent by one count
two hundred and seventy seven days on the
golf course during his presidency.
That's twenty one point eight percent of his
presidency.
And of the two hundred and seventy seven days
that he golfed on all but eight meaning to
sixty nine.
He went to courses he owns, which is yet another
way in which he has handsomely profited from
the presidency, funneling taxpayer money,
your money, my money into his courses by requiring
a full mobilization of government and Secret
Service to resorts and golf courses that he
owns.
So that's one context.
The other context is also that Donald Trump
claimed during Barack Obama's presidency that
Obama golf too much and that he wouldn't have
any time for golfing.
Remember some of this stuff, because I'm going
to be working for you.
I'm not going to have time to go play golf.
I don't have time for that.
I love golf.
I think it's one of the greats.
But I don't have to go.
If I were in the White House, I just want
to stay in the White House and worked my ass
off.
Right.
And then even more specifically, because there's
a tweet for everything Trump tweeted in October
of 2014 as the Ebola.
I can't call it a pandemic as the Ebola situation
was going on, which led to two deaths in the
United States.
Trump tweeted, quote, Can you believe that
with all of the problems and difficulties
facing the U.S., President Obama spent the
day playing golf worse than Carter.
So, of course, Trump golfs all the time more
than Obama when not two, but one hundred and
thirty seven thousand Americans have died
from Corona virus.
And he tweets this bizarre defense of his
golfing.
Take a look at this, saying, quote, I know
many in business and politics that work out
endlessly, in some cases to a point of exhaustion.
It is their number one passion in life, but
nobody complaints.
My exercise is playing almost never during
the week.
A quick round of golf.
Obama played more and much longer rounds.
No problem.
When I play fake news, CNN and others park
themselves anywhere they can to get a picture.
Then scream President Trump is playing golf.
Actually, I play very fast, get a lot of work
done on the golf course and also get a tiny
bit of exercise.
Not bad.
So does this require analysis?
None of it makes sense.
He first, weirdly starts by saying some people
work out too much and they end up tired.
I'm not going to do that now.
I don't think anybody mistakenly thought Trump
was going to work out so much that he'd be
he'd be overtired from it.
I think we knew that.
But he says golfing is actually his exercise.
Now, of course, he drives a golf cart around.
So the exercise part is actually pretty limited,
walking nine holes with your clubs, walking
18 holes with your clubs.
It's really very good exercise.
Trump doesn't do that.
But then he adds in.
I'm not playing during the week, only on weekends.
But in any case, Obama golf more than I did,
which is untrue.
But in any case, he's playing really fast.
So he's not spending that much time on the
golf course and he's getting a lot of work
on the golf course.
So this is about four or five different arguments,
some of which conflict with each with each
other.
But most importantly, he told us he wasn't
going to have time for golf.
And these are not normal times.
We have a global pandemic, which he has handled
worse than almost anybody than any other world
leaders.
And he's not only spending time golfing.
He's spending time tweeting about golfing.
Now, the counter argument is one I've made
before, which is Trump fails at the things
he works on.
So don't we like if he golfed all the time,
maybe Corona virus handling would be left
to people who are competent.
But we know that's not how it actually works
when he's gone.
It's that lunatic Peter Navarro.
And, you know, whoever else, it's not Dr.
Fouche.
She runs the show when Trump is golfing and
putting aside the human toll of Corona virus
for a moment.
That's that's the most important thing from
a political standpoint.
Many presidents would have jumped at a pandemic
as a way to secure their reelection.
I've said this before.
If Donald Trump had properly handled Corona
virus, if Trump said at the beginning, we
are going to do the best on this, I am going
to get reelected for how well I'm going to
handle this.
Trump could have an almost Guerin's.
He'd reelection one of the areas on which
Biden is crushing Trump the most is perceptions
of handling of Corona virus.
If Trump had handled that well, Biden would
not be leading the way that he's leading right
now.
Trump would need no October surprise if he
simply managed this properly.
That's mindblowing to think about because,
as usual, Trump's problems are mostly self-inflicted.
The virus is not self-inflicted.
But look at New Zealand, right?
You have a historically popular leader there
because of how she dealt with the virus.
She didn't cause the virus, but she handled
it.
Donald Trump hasn't.
And it's yet another one of these partially
self-inflicted disasters for Donald Trump.